one of the sort of side stories with
what's going on on twitter with this
reportedly accepted offer for elon musk
to purchase twitter and to take it
private one of the side stories that's
come up and many of you have emailed me
about it many of you have noticed how it
has affected my twitter account
is the
significant number of uh followers that
many left-leaning accounts have lost on
twitter and so i'm going to explain this
story
as i currently know it and i'm going to
try to be as accurate and precise as
possible without going beyond what we
know and what's been said because it is
still sort of a developing story so the
way that this started is right around
sunday monday tuesday when we learned
about this effort that has reportedly
been accepted by twitter although it's
not yet been approved it's been accepted
in principle but it hasn't happened and
it still may not for elon musk to buy
twitter
we started seeing overwhelming anecdotal
reports of high-profile twitter accounts
and verified twitter accounts reporting
losing huge numbers of followers
right in that period of time where it
started to become known that elon musk
may be buying twitter
and initially the assumption was before
twitter put out any statement you saw a
lot of venture capital and investment
type people saying what's happening here
is twitter is cleaning up the bots and
the fake accounts
for the sale because part of what you
need to this was the story they were
telling there was no evidence for this
but they were saying you know when
you're going to part of the valuation is
based on the number of users and so you
want to feel really good that you can
give an accurate number of real people
that are using the service so you want
to eliminate bots and fake accounts
and it may be that the more followers
you have the more fake followers that
you have
it never struck me as accurate i don't
think that just an agreement in
principle would immediately start some
kind of algorithmic closure of accounts
believed to be fake or bots so it just
wasn't logical it's possible that would
be done
but the idea that it would start
instantly upon the news breaking of elon
musk's purchase it just didn't really
make any sense but the numbers were
pretty stunning a former president
barack obama who's one of the most
followed people on twitter maybe the
most followed he lost more than 300 000
followers after the announcement on
monday
my verified account my tiny little teeny
weeny verified account
lost about a thousand followers in that
monday tuesday period um between sunday
and tuesday nancy pelosi lost like 13
000 followers elizabeth warren lost 14
000 followers bernie sanders lost 19 000
followers but
then it appeared that not everybody was
actually losing followers because some
right wing accounts
we're seeing massive dumps of new
followers come in um marjorie taylor
green the radical trumpist congresswoman
personally she's banned on twitter
but her congressional account is still
active i know whatever that's not even
the whether that makes sense or not it's
not the issue marjorie taylor green's
account
saw a record new 100 000 followers over
that two-day period i you know i lost a
thousand she gained a hundred thousand
so that can't be because of purging bots
because some people were gaining
followers and they seemed to be mostly
right-wingers well twitter has now
spoken out about it twitter says that
the follower changes that have been
observed are coming from quote
natural account terminations
uh a spokesperson at twitter who spoke
on the condition of anonymity said
the more high profile the account the
more of a fluctuation we've seen but
these are not bot closures
this is just people closing accounts and
people signing up so the current claim
from twitter is i lost a thousand
followers because a thousand of my
followers were genuinely mad that elon
musk is buying twitter and so they went
and they closed their twitter accounts
and at the same time marjorie taylor
green gained a hundred thousand
followers because i guess right wingers
presumably happy that elon musk is
buying twitter
said i'm gonna make a twitter account or
i'm gonna take my dormant twitter
account and start following people like
marjorie taylor green because i'm ready
for the free speech and all of the
different things that elon musk is going
to bring uh ted cruz gained more than 50
000 followers matt gates gained about 25
000 followers right wing nut brazilian
president jair bolsonaro gained close to
a hundred thousand followers so
do we believe this do we believe this i
i mean if it it can't be that this was a
bot purge because the right wing
accounts are gaining followers
if the belief is these are the natural
reactions leftists are mad about elon
musk so they're closing accounts and
right wingers are thrilled about elon
musk buying it so they're signing up
if that's the case it's a concern
because of what it signals that twitter
may become
the other part of it is
i mean listen
it's striking me as a little bit of a
statistical improbability
that you would see such partisan changes
to followers so quickly it's just kind
of weird we work with algorithms all the
time and genkuger tweeted something
similar we see
how these things have happened over long
periods of times on a time on youtube
and on different platforms
i just don't know that i buy it i i
don't know i'm not accusing anyone in
particular of lying maybe it's a
combination of things and of course if
the explanation that twitter is giving
is a lie well it's a concern that
twitter is lying so to me this is a red
flag either way
my personal
behavior on twitter is i continue to
mute every annoying account because
twitter has always been filled with lots
of right wing trolls i actually looked
at my account the other day
what it would look like without
thousands of trolls muted it would be
completely unusable and what's really
funny is there are people who have been
tweeting trash to me on twitter for
years they've had no idea that i can't
see their tweets
and for years that it made me laugh a
little bit that there's so many of them
but as far as what we know now twitter
saying the fluctuations left wingers
losing followers right wingers gaining
followers this is a reflection of
natural
uh account creation and deletion which
if true
raises real questions about what the
future of twitter looks like under elon
musk on today's bonus show we're going
to examine
elon musk's history of speech
as a defender or not of free speech
which has been very much at issue here
that'll be on today's bonus show i want
to play a clip for you today from c-span
now c-span is not a place
where you necessarily expect
the most sort of unhinged political
discussion c-span generally does a good
job of
moderating relatively sober and
respectful discussion even when kind of
kooky people call in they tend to do a
pretty good job with it well during the
show washington journal on c-span
recently there was a caller from
tennessee and that caller called in
upset
that there were minorities on his tv
screen giving opinions and he said he
doesn't like it he wants to go back to
the way things kind of used to be and
for those who are only listening to this
clip there's an asian guy and a black
woman who are on the panel on washington
journal and the guy is nicholas wu from
politico
the woman is ebony mcmorris from the
american urban radio network and
take a look at this and then we'll
discuss it this is really something
comment for them please when i was a
little boy listen i'm 83 years old when
i was a little boy
i think that by the way i think the
caller is a man although although maybe
not i don't know
okay we're going to stop it there let's
go to nancy apologies i'm sorry and i
and i didn't even start it at the
beginning let's go to the beginning i
apologize current things here in america
that's going on particularly
in the press
and uh the politics
of america
i want to know
if uh
we could cut out some of this
if we could cut out some of these uh
these liberal things that are going on
in america just like in on the tv now
we have two minorities and i'm not
giving you minorities
i'm 83 years old caller this that's that
shouldn't be a factor in the vicus that
we invite to our program which we did
invite so what's your question or
comment for them please when i was a
little boy listen i'm 83 years old when
i was a little boy the colored people
here okay we're going to stop it there
let's go to nancy apologies for that
uh the colored people are bothering this
83 year old man or woman now i know many
people will react to this by saying this
is an 83 year old these are not common
views well the issue here is that
these are actually relatively
these are more common views than we
would like to admit but a lot of younger
people realize you can't say that out
loud you're not supposed to out loud say
i'm really bothered by all these
non-white people i'm seeing in movies
and on television and they even
sometimes just call it woke i mean woke
for some people has become a a
paraphrase in a sense for
i'm seeing a lot of liberals with
different identities uh participating
and being allowed to give opinions and i
don't like that now ebony mcmorris who
was
the the black woman on the panel
she tweeted after the fact quote i was
trying to hold it in but i promise you i
felt all my ancestors rushed through my
body
nicholas wu was right pedro was a master
at intercepting that next time the
response may be different
and this is really you know the person
says i don't i don't have a problem with
minorities so what they're kind of
saying is i'm not a racist i just don't
want minorities on my tv screen giving
me political opinions i don't want too
many minorities in my government or in
my neighborhood or in the same waiting
rooms as me type of moment and what
really makes me kind of sad it bums me
out
the looks on the faces of the guests
there's a bit of a i've dealt with this
before sort of look and that is
that that's that's sad it really is and
so when we talk about well when they say
that they're conservative
what do they want to conserve or what
what do they want to go back to because
for many of them they believe we've
already gone too far they want
conserving means actually let's go back
we often say vaguely well they want to
go back to sort of the 50s right where
yes there were minorities around but
they were much more
it was much more okay to openly say
these are second-tier people they're not
like us yes women were around but they
were much more uh stringently
subservient to men they're talking about
the 50s and if this is an 83 year old
caller
1955 they would have been about 16 years
old
that is exactly what they are kind of
thinking back to and this is different
this is
what is also fascinating
is because of the trump era
we're really used to the neo-reactionary
cartoonish conservative jfk junior's
still alive and
queuing on and this type of stuff
this is much more
the 1950s conservative
that we would see a lot more like in the
bush era when they would talk about the
moral majority and getting back to god
and christianity and all these different
things that's this collar this is not
really it it doesn't sound to me a trump
is neo-reactionary it's more of of that
and it's quite saddened it's still
around 83 years old but it's still
around send me your thoughts you can
find me on twitter
deepakman we'll take a quick break and
be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show does depend on our
audience to support the work that we do
we are audience funded viewers listeners
to the podcast people watching on free
speech tv or checking out a youtube clip
here or there we have a membership
program you can sign up at
joinpackman.com we do an extra show
every day for our members called the
bonus show and alex jones really doesn't
like the bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad yeah i love the bonus show alex
jones hates it take that uh however you
will you can sign up at joinpackman.com
you'll also get a commercial free audio
and video stream of the show every
single day up to six hours before
everybody else gets it it's some pretty
big time stuff and i would love for you
to sign up
our friend michael cohen donald trump's
former personal attorney
he seems to be putting his foot down and
saying hey guys either indict trump or
i'm out and i'm going to stop
cooperating and i have to tell you i
sympathize with michael cohen 100
so let's go through what's going on
there's a good daily beast piece called
manhattan d.a star witness indict trump
now or i'm out the piece is by jose
paglieri
and it reads if manhattan prosecutors
don't indict former president donald
trump with the grand jury they've got in
the next nine days
the key witness investigators used to
build their entire case says he won't
help revive it in the future they're
talking of course about michael cohen
the new york lawyer trump used for years
as his families as his family companies
trusted consigliere told the daily beast
he's already wasted too much of his time
on a case that slowly and then suddenly
doesn't seem to be going anywhere
prosecutors only have until the current
grand jury's term expires on april 30 to
issue charges at which point they must
ask jurors who have already done this
for six months to continue hearing
evidence or call the whole thing off
and awkwardly make the entire
presentation all over again for another
23 jurors if this grand jury is let go
cohen won't play ball asked if he'd be
willing to sit down again with
investigators or testify at a future
trial against trump cohen responded with
utter exasperation no i've spent
countless hours 15 sessions including
three while incarcerated i provided
thousands of documents which coupled
with my testimony would have been a
valid basis for an indictment and charge
the fact that they have not done so
despite all of this i'm not interested
in any further investment of my time i
have to tell you this makes perfect
perfect sense now some people are mad at
michael cohen saying wait a second
you have the knowledge
you have the information
hell you're the one who actually was
found guilty of crimes related to doing
trump's bidding and now you're going to
bail but i this make makes 100 sense to
me remember we have now learned about
the resignation of investigators
in an investigation into donald trump
why did the investigators resign
they resigned because they saw that
there was enough evidence not only to
charge trump but they felt to clearly
get convictions and yet it didn't seem
to them like there was actually any
political interest in bringing forth
charges against donald trump
why are you sitting around doing this
type of work if it's not going to go
anywhere what there's a torture
technique
and or it's just a way to kind of uh
make people exasperated right and you
we've heard about this like when we talk
about hard labor in prison over time in
history sometimes one thing that was
done is you you just have people break
rocks and then move them and then move
them back
and knowing that what you're doing is
going to go absolutely nowhere
is absolutely demoralizing and so i
understand the investigators saying what
are we just doing this for fun is this
just an academic exercise because there
seems to be no willingness to actually
charge donald trump they resigned and
michael cohen seems to be feeling
something pretty similar i've given you
everything i testified while
incarcerated i've provided documents i'm
giving hell i got in trouble for the
stuff that trump directed me to do which
was against the law
and it's going nowhere and the grand
jury is set to end on april 30th so
this is very clearly one of the most
blatant political non-prosecutions that
i've seen in the world of you know
national american politics cohen is at
this point understandably exasperated
multiple people around trump have gone
to prison for crimes they did either for
or in coordination with trump we've had
multiple investigations
what what are we doing we've seen
campaign finance violations we've seen
obstruction we've seen the removal and
mishandling of classified documents we
arguably have seen uh election fraud
conspiracy in at minimum in the state of
georgia and these are just the obvious
ones let's not even talk about the
multiple conspiracies elsewhere the rest
of america i think is now seeing
the
disenfranchisement that so many groups
have felt for a long time right i mean
the non-rich know about the two justice
systems
minorities know about being treated in a
particular way by police
jews and muslims know about religious
discrimination remember in the united
states when we look at religious hate
crimes it's jews and muslims that are
primarily targeted we now are all seeing
exactly how this plays out wait so he
gets treated one way and everybody else
gets treated a different way yep that's
exactly what's going on
so i as much as the next guy would want
to see charges brought but i understand
why michael cohen is putting his foot
down how much more of his life has to be
devoted to testifying and giving
evidence uh and having lawyers himself
remember
um when it's not even clear that there's
really a willingness to bring charges so
we'll see what happens there's three
more days until this grand jury is done
and then we'll see what happens after
that
one of the questions that we regularly
ask each other people call in they ask
me i ask producer pat
we're regular i ask guests
are these
lunatic conspiracy theorists
particularly when it comes to the
election the election fraud alleged of
2020
do they really believe it or is it just
something they say to show that they're
on the team so when we see a poll that a
while ago said oh 57 percent of trump
voters believe trump won even though he
didn't
we ask the question
do they literally believe trump won or
do they see saying trump one as how they
signal that they're on trump's team
it could be one the other could be a
combination of the two
when it comes to my pillow ceo mike
lindell we now have a leaked test text
message that tells us he's a true
believer we see pillow come out and say
all these things oh it's the machines
and remember he wanted to sue all
machines we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines right and
we wonder could this guy possibly be for
real well it turns out that on december
20th of 2020 pillow texted trump chief
of staff mike lindell the text message
is longer than a cvs receipt so we're
going to look at it in pieces but the
takeaway is
he really is a believer look at what he
this is not something he said publicly
this is a private text message to mark
meadows and mike pillow believes it all
it reads
hey mark i felt i was supposed to text
you this message you being a man
of faith and on the front line of the
decisions that are going to be
historical i guess he means historic i
would ask that you pray for wisdom and
discernment from god you are one of the
people the president trusts the most
that being said i want to add my input
everything sydney he's referring to
sidney powell trump's
i guess lawyer at the time everything
sydney has said is true we have the
machines and everything we already have
proves the president won by millions of
votes i have read and not validated yet
that you and others talked him out of
seizing them if true i prayed as part of
a bigger plan this is pillow wanting the
voting machines to be seized by trump i
am grateful that on the night of the
election the algorithms of the corrupt
machines broke and they realized our
president would win in spite of the
historical fraud i look for deviations
every day in my business when i find one
i investigate relentlessly until i know
why it happened and how it happened this
is my gift from god that has made my
business so successful
he's a he's a real believer
he is completely out of his mind he goes
on to write to mark meadows from 11 15
pm on the night of the election i have
spent all my time running impossible
deviations and numbers from this
election
what i also was blessed to be able to
get info and help sydney lin general
flynn
and everyone else out there gathering
all the massive evidence i have been
sickened by politicians especially
republican judges the media not wanting
to see the truth no matter what the
truth would be this is the biggest
cover-up of one of the worst crimes in
history i have spent over a million
dollars to help uncover this fraud and
use my platform so people can get the
word
not give up not to give up
the people on both sides have to see the
truth and when they do there will be no
civil war people
including politicians are fearing the
only thing any of us should fear is fear
of the lord every person on this planet
needs to know the truth and see the
evidence mark
god has his hand in all of this and has
put you on the front line i will
continue praying for you to have great
wisdom and discernment blessings mike
and uh mark meadows responded thanks
brother
pray for a miracle
he
really believes it
and the reason we care about this is
that it's arguably harder to deal with
people who really believe it with people
who only say it
you merely have to convince them it's no
longer in their interest to say it but
they already didn't believe it so it's
much simpler and more straightforward
when you have a real believer like this
it is much more difficult to disabuse
them of these beliefs and to deprogram
them and that's obviously what we're
coming up against right now the the kind
of silliest part is where he sees that
there are some impossible deviations
like as if pillow has any idea how
statistics work or any idea how to apply
them in the real world but more
importantly
we still haven't actually seen any of
the data that this is supposedly based
on and that's maybe the wackiest thing
which is going all the way back to the
beginning pillow has insisted we have
machines we have data we have uh all we
have all of it we've run statistical
analysis okay well when are you going to
show us the data oh i'll show it to you
at my symposium or my symposium as he
would call it and then he didn't show
anything and then it's been a year
almost a year and a half now if you have
the data it would be great for you to
show it it's always a week away from
coming out
my guess is they don't have it but if
these text messages prove anything it's
that he really believes this and i think
it's safe to believe
at least some portion of other
republicans truly believe it as well
sure some of them just say it yeah trump
won trump won i believe that trump won
if trump stopped saying it they would
stop saying it too
but mike lindell
truly genuinely and sincerely seems to
believe this fairy tale and that makes
it all the more difficult to deal with
we'll have the text message up on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
david pakman show where you can get
access to behind the scenes videos the
daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show as well as special discounts
on merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show in psychology
projection is displacing your feelings
onto someone else and in politics or
colloquially we sometimes call
projection
when you blame others for doing
something which actually you were the
one who is guilty of doing and it's very
hard to imagine any better example of
that in the modern political landscape
than republicans obsessing about
supposed democratic voter fraud voter
impersonation and other hijinks when it
is actually anecdotally they themselves
that are doing it even though overall
it's extraordinarily rare we now have
another example of this as a republican
has pleaded guilty to voting in two
different states and again the big
picture story is that this type of thing
is very rare
not very easy to do
and has never impacted any election to
the degree that it would actually affect
the results at the micro level when
individual instances of voter fraud
actually take place it's almost
exclusively republicans who are actually
doing it sometimes to quote test the
system they claim
uh or listen i killed him just to see if
the police are that good at solving
murders give me a break okay
and sometimes it is because they are
actually trying to do it
they just want to vote twice or whatever
the case may be in this article we have
learned of a new hampshire republican
who voted in two states
a man who voted in both new hampshire
and massachusetts in the 2016 general
election has been ordered to pay nearly
five thousand dollars in fines and
penalties
now i think it's also important to
mention that sometimes when people have
accidentally voted illegally they get
prison time there's a famous story of a
black woman who um
wasn't even deliberately voting multiple
times she just wasn't supposed to vote
and she did
she went to jail
in this case todd kriziak
is having to pay a five thousand dollar
fine
was charged in june of 2019 pleaded
guilty friday to voting in more than one
state he was given a 90-day suspended
sentence a 4 000 fine and a roughly
thousand dollar penalty he cast ballots
in alton new hampshire
and leominster massachusetts on election
day of 2016. krisyak was registered as a
republican in alton attorney david
bedanza said his client voted in alton
where he lives
later visited in mother in massachusetts
she said hey
your name is on the list here where he
previously lived so he went there and
voted as well he went down to vote
thinking that he could
does anyone believe that is there any
adult you know we had this story after
the um in november there was the
virginia gubernatorial election where
glenn younkin won defeated terry
mcauliffe and we learned that his 17
young 17 year old kid
went and tried to vote i believe it was
twice but at least tried to vote once
and he was turned away because he's not
18 years old
and later
glenn young chalked it up to he didn't
know he couldn't vote he thought you
know he might be able to vote
is it believable that there's any 17
year old in this country i'm not talking
about someone you know from from someone
who's been kept out of school and has
never watched tv and but just like a
normal upper middle class 17 year old
who goes to a good school
that doesn't know you have to be 18 to
vote it's just not believable this is
even less believable i thought i could
vote in both places i thought i could
vote twice
what
um
that doesn't make any sense even weirder
is that bodanza called the plea a fair
resolution but said the case raised
unanswered questions about whether
krisiak acted knowingly in regard to
each element of the crime he said his
client didn't intend to vote in
massachusetts when he voted in new
hampshire
so that and understand just the bizarre
nature of that he said he thought he
could vote twice when he went to vote in
new hampshire at that point he wasn't
thinking i'll also vote in massachusetts
so the new hampshire vote wasn't
fraudulent it wasn't part of planning to
vote twice
his mom gave him the idea by saying you
know i saw you're still registered in
massachusetts as well and so then he
said well i'll go and vote oh so it's
not as bad because when you went to new
hampshire it wasn't part of give me a
break guys now i think it's very
important to to issue one other uh
reminder here
we on the left who care about facts
should distinguish
from
between when they lie
versus when they tell the truth about
something that's not actually a problem
so what do i mean by that
they would spread the lie after 2020.
tons of dead people voted
okay well no actually
dead people didn't vote what they often
mean by that is a live people go and
they say my name is such and such and
it's the name of a dead person and they
vote in that person's name number one
that hasn't happened number two it's a
really bad way to win an election
because there's not so many of those
people that you could actually in a
reasonable way flip an election there's
just not enough hours in the day on
election day however
it sometimes happens
that
someone fills out and sends in an
absentee ballot
legally they're alive
then they die before election day
okay
that is a clerical issue
they've not done anything against the
law they were alive when they sent in
their absentee ballot here's another
example
people voted twice well
when sometimes people actually vote
twice
we find out it's a republican and we
found it recently with some trump
supporters down in the villages in
florida we found it with this guy
however sometimes what they mean is hey
we found someone who's registered in two
places that's not a crime
that's a clerical issue as long as you
only vote in one place it's not a big
deal when i moved to new york from
massachusetts there was a period of time
where i was still registered in
massachusetts and then i went and i
signed up to vote in new york uh no
problem i was registered twice for a
period of time i didn't vote in both
places i didn't do anything wrong
tiffany trump trump's daughter exact
same situation
um
so let's distinguish between things that
they say are happening that aren't
and things that they say are happening
that are happening but aren't actually a
problem it's not illegal it's not
against the law there's no crime there's
no wrongdoing a lot of these are just
clerical issues this guy voted twice
knowingly he's paying a five thousand
dollar fine
speaking by oh by the way we have to
talk about this this is going to sound
speaking of two justice systems
this is going to sound like a story we
already did i know you're going to say
david
i know you did that story it is not an
old story it happened again
radical repugnant
trumpist congressman madison cawthorne
has been caught with a gun at an airport
again now i know you remember the story
or you might
it's because it's happened multiple
times
in august of 2021
we did the story madison cawthorne tried
to board a plane with a gun because he
did it was in his carry-on he said i
didn't know it was in my carry-on that's
what we call negligent gun ownership you
don't know where the gun is that's not
very responsible he had another run-in
with the law involving weapons in
september 20 uh september 21st of 2021
madison cawthorne brought a big knife to
a school board meeting those aren't
allowed in schools
but he is not going to be charged for
that either
and now we have yet another story
congressman madison cawthorne cited for
a loaded gun loaded loaded
in his bag at an airport checkpoint
this was this week folks
madison cawthorne was cited tuesday for
having a gun at a security checkpoint at
charlotte airport this is the second
time he's violated rules
that prohibit traveling with firearms
and carry-on bags cothorn was cited for
possession of a dangerous weapon on city
property and then released
authorities took possession of the
loaded gun which is standard procedure
according to the tsa this happened
around 9 am a tsa officer spotted the
gun in a bag
the police say cawthorne stated the
firearm was his and he was cooperative
a report from charlotte police on
twitter says on tuesday yesterday april
26th police officers assigned to the
airport were notified by the tsa that a
firearm was located in a bag
at a security screening checkpoint
responding officers identified the owner
of the bag as david madison cawthorne
kawthorne stated the firearm was his and
he was cooperative with officers
a police report indicates officers
recovered a staccato c2 firearm magazine
and nine millimeter
nine millimeter rounds of ammunition the
gun was loaded loaded loaded loaded
so
is there going to be any serious or
repercussion for madison cawthorne you
claim to be for law and order just
follow the law now how many times are
you allowed to be caught with firearms
at airport security before you get put
on a no-fly list and by the way
loaded it's against the law
to bring on a carry-on a gun even if it
is unloaded
this was a loaded firearm this is the
epitome of irresponsible gun ownership
gun owners should know where their guns
are at all times
if you're unaware of where your firearm
is
that is negligent gun ownership and
number two
you should not be carrying the firearms
around loaded in this way
i understand if you are someone who
concealed carries or open carries your
firearm's going to be loaded that's sort
of like the point
here we're talking about a very
different situation
where you are um going you're traveling
you're going through airport security
my friends who have firearms and again i
always i never talk about some a lot of
times people ask about my personal gun
ownership and stuff like i just don't
talk about that i don't see any reason
to talk about that but my friends who
have firearms
have theirs locked unless in transit or
in use
and if you're careless with a firearm if
you don't know where it is if it's
loaded when it's supposed to be unloaded
it's not responsible gun ownership by
its very definition and and we've talked
about this before in the context of
there was an accidental shooting well
what you mean is there was a negligent
discharge of a firearm you didn't mean
to fire it
and you fired it that's irresponsible
with the very rare exception of the
spontaneously firing weapon i know we
once interviewed a lawyer
about i believe it was a remington rifle
defect where it would sometimes quite
literally spontaneously fire
that's you know 0.001 percent of these
situations if the gun fires and you
fired it accidentally that is a
negligent discharge and it's often just
that it was just it was not an accident
it wasn't oh okay an accident we were
talking about a negligent discharge and
irresponsible gun ownership and madison
cawthorne's behavior with firearms is
extraordinarily irresponsible what
should happen to him
i i don't know
uh airports and airport police have long
had significant discretion when this
happens you can go on youtube and find
many examples of people who
bring a firearm or attempt to bring it
through security
and it's not uncommon that well they're
cooperative and the gun is kept at the
airport until they come back or whatever
with madison cawthorne it's now become a
habitual thing and we're talking about
loaded rather than unloaded guns i don't
know what should happen but it doesn't
really seem like it's being taken
seriously by the justice system let me
know your thoughts we'll take a quick
break and be right back
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
we've used the term stochastic terrorism
before on the show stochastic terrorism
is sort of the idea that while not being
a physical in-person terrorist yourself
if you have a big enough audience and
you float an idea to them of doing
something with a big enough audience it
becomes statistically more and more
likely that someone in the audience is
going to listen to what you're saying
and they're going to go out there and
they're going to commit an act of terror
we've looked at a number of these
examples in the past one is a guy
who used to listen to glenn beck rant
and rave about an organization called
the tides foundation and was actually
intercepted by california highway patrol
armed and heading to do something at the
tides foundation comet ping pong is
another example when republicans were
going crazy about the pizzagate
conspiracy theory and this pizza shop in
washington dc and saying they're
harboring pedophiles they're helping you
know whatever it was they were saying
pedophiles are meeting here and
trafficking young kids or whatever a guy
actually went and shot up comet ping
pong so there's a real effect here
republicans um a republican audience
listening to
the chairman of the oklahoma republican
party john bennett who's also running
for house of representatives they
cheered when john bennett said
we should kill fauci we should put fauci
in front of a firing squad now i'm
certain
that john bennett is a pro-life
and i'm certain that john bennett uh is
a christian
because there's uh a jersey up on the
screen behind him that says
aphasians ephesians i don't even know
how to pronounce it and there's a cross
and so this is a pro-life christian guy
in case you weren't sure and here he is
saying well we should put fauci in front
of a firing squad we're fighting
communist democrats no you're not
there's no communists in the house and
senate establishment rhinos we're
fighting against a system that stole the
election in 2020 and nobody's been held
accountable
[Applause]
we're in a war with bureaucrats that
have forced vaccine mandates on us
masked mandates on us and you know what
they're pushing this wokeness confusion
down our throats now and by the way we
should try anthony fauci and put him in
front of a firing squad a firing squad
whoa
[Applause]
and the crowd loves it they love it
and for the secret service if they're
listening
i'm not advocating we kill anthony fauci
until he's convicted of his crimes
through a court right a nice little
clarification there now of course this
this guy is very pro-life and he
respects life and he's christian and all
these different things now threatening
government officials in the united
states
is illegal under federal law my guess is
the law doesn't apply to john bennett
right that that wouldn't really make any
sense
so kill anthony fauci put him in front
of a firing squad um this is
unfortunately not something we can just
laugh off and write off
there are really truly dangerous people
who want to see fouchy dead you know how
we know it isn't a joke
fauci has full-time armed security
he did anyway for the years during the
heart of the pandemic i don't know if
they've been able to ease up on it now
or not my guess is if stuff like this is
going on he probably still needs the
full-time armed security now lots of
people would say something like this
about a public figure
in a social media status update and you
would get a visit from law enforcement
if you said it about the president or
vice president or maybe even the speaker
of the house or a prominent senator you
might even get a visit from secret
service and yet here it's become normal
to call for executions in public forums
and then you say to secret service i'm
not really there you know we'll kill
them after we try them or whatever even
if like what are you the debt why would
they even get the death penalty for
whatever you think they did which they
didn't this is proof
that you have this critical mass
of lack of intelligence
glorified by a base of people who are
extraordinarily radical
and the fear-mongering that's used
against them remember this is the
reactionary toolbox can be used to
actually trigger them to go out and take
real-world actions and remember that uh
you know we we were told time and time
again
that this movement that is being built
the maga movement and so on and so forth
this is a special movement this is a a
unique movement it was unique and that
these were a lot of people
who because they had never followed or
been involved in politics before
they had no idea of what was over the
line when it came to political discourse
and as a result
trump combined with these folks who had
i don't know they just like i guess
trump's the guy i never really paid
attention to politics what trump does
must be normal
it immediately
normalized for lack of a better term
um this type of political discourse
locking up people that haven't even been
charged with a crime
uh talking about eliminating people
firing squads etc now how many of them
are actually willing to do violence i
don't think it's that many but the thing
is
think through some numbers
73 74 million people voted for donald
trump
if it's only two percent of those voters
that are willing to do violence right
that's still a million and a half people
that's that's a lot of people who are
potentially willing to do violence a lot
of the people willing to do violence
also don't vote at all so it's probably
actually an even higher number
unfortunately when you look at numbers
like one in four republican voters
believe some aspect of q anon
it's probably more than two percent of
those republican voters that are
theoretically willing to use violence
and you know what we know it's more how
do we know a recent poll found that
about 30 percent of republicans believed
it would be acceptable to use violence
now that doesn't mean they'd be the ones
doing it but if 30 percent of
republicans say violence would be
acceptable
at least a portion of them would be
willing to go out and do it so
unfortunately the numbers aren't good
and we're gonna go on now to something
else where it's really not looking good
our friends over at the good liars
they're really good at this stuff they
talk to people at different political
events they go to anti-vaccine events
they go to trump rallies they go to all
sorts of different things
they were able to find and how hard they
had to look i don't really know it's
probably pretty easy at these events
they found a woman
who believes that joe biden is currently
being played by actors in other words
they're sort of like i guess body
doubles in makeup i don't know
and one of the actors that
this woman believes is playing joe biden
is the great comedic actor jim carrey
let's play it and then we're going to
talk about it and i know that this is
funny in some ways but this is actually
really scary and
we'll we'll talk about that you think
biden is not alive right now no the guy
that's doing the stand-up job of trying
to wake people up is an actor wearing a
mask i mean there's several different
people playing joe biden at this point
and when when he fell up the stairs
going on the airplane
i myself think that that was jim carrey
now why would it be jim carrey i i don't
know i would love to get an explanation
about that i've heard that he was one of
them
wait wait wait wait you think that
jim carrey was wearing a mask right and
was the acting president and being silly
by falling up the stairs three different
times
and james woods also i think is one of
the
doppelganger mask wearing
people now isn't james what i don't want
to say this incorrectly but i thought
james woods was a republican why would
he be uh
james woods has praised trump yeah i
don't know why james woods would be
willing to be part of the subterfuge so
listen i i'm going to take this
seriously i'm going to take this
seriously i don't want to joke about
this
it can be really hard to figure out a
diagnosis for folks uh like this i i
spoke to some psychiatrists about this
when we see someone like this and we say
okay is this
is this uh like what is happening here
we try to make sense of how someone
could end up believing stuff like this
one possibility is what's called
delusional disorder you're delusional
okay it's a type of psychosis where a
person can't tell what is real and
what's imagined so as real as this
microphone is for me
the person sees as just just as real
that jim carrey and james woods are
playing the role of biden who has died
and the main feature of delusional
disorder is the presence of delusions
which are truly unshakable beliefs that
something is true and people with
delusional disorder often can continue
to socialize seemingly normally you
could go and have lunch with this woman
and talk about the weather and whatever
and it's the subject of their delusion
where
it's it's just wacky but their other
behavior is not obviously odd or bizarre
like they're not all collecting feces at
home you know or whatever like they just
they live normally but they have these
specific unshakable delusional beliefs
now delusional disorder by itself is
actually pretty rarely diagnosed it
typically occurs
in middle age or later and the causes
can be genetic biological environmental
now that would point to why
people who have one set of delusional
beliefs that they often hold strange
beliefs about a few things but again
they typically function normally now the
other day we mentioned a
different but similar condition it's
called paraphrenia disorder so it might
sound like schizophrenia it's not it's
something different paraphrenia is a
mental disorder
characterized by a very organized system
of paranoid delusions they don't have to
have hallucinations and that typically
onset is later in life 60 plus
and paraphrenia doesn't have its own
section in the dsm-5 because often when
someone
presents with paraphrenia uh they end up
being diagnosed with delusional disorder
so these these are very
blurry lines and they can be hard to
sort of diagnose
this is more common in women
now let's take it a step further again
we're taking this seriously saying do
these people just need to be convinced
or do they need medication we're trying
to really think it through in a serious
manner there's a study that opens the
door even wider
the study is called
belief in conspiracy theories the
predictive role of schizotype
machiavellianism and primary psychopathy
what this study looks at is whether
schizotype machiavellianism
grandiose narcissism vulnerable
narcissism primary psychopathy and
secondary psychopathy are good
predictors of how likely someone is to
believe conspiracy theories now
this correlation wouldn't necessarily
say to us well if you have someone with
a specific delusional conspiracy theory
like this woman it doesn't guarantee
that they are psychopaths or they are
uh
schizophrenic or whatever the case may
be
but it might have some kind of
predictive role about how likely are
those folks to end up believing some of
these things and then you could kind of
work backwards and try to figure out is
there medication that will help
this is really serious stuff uh the
psychiatrists i've spoken to and my dad
is a psychiatrist have said
sometimes
medications can help folks like this
but it is not super typical
that if you give someone who's
quite ill with these types of beliefs a
pill
that four weeks later or eight weeks
later
they no longer believe any of this stuff
the
paranoia or the delusion might be less
intrusive
they might be less focused on it it
might form less of a sort of obsessive
nature for them they might not be at the
trump rallies talking to people
but uh this is still a not completely
well understood area of mental health
now what do we know for sure
there's too much stigma around mental
health treatment in the united states we
have a lot of undiagnosed mental illness
in the united states and we have a lot
of we have not nearly enough access to
mental health treatment and that's part
partially a stigma thing it's partially
a health care system thing and this is
really a big deal but this goes well
beyond politics and i think that that's
the important thing to understand
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
um this is a voicemail from troy york we
haven't heard from him for a while he
calls in with my podcast playing in the
background and that's indeed what
happened here he is unleashing a very
serious criticism against me because i
once ate food when i was in san diego
california listen to this
um uh david peckham
uh when when i heard your recent
broadcast you took a phone call
from a guy from san diego
and you said you were in san diego
and you loved all the restaurants
when you said that this pretty much
demonstrates
what i always thought
um
you are a elitist
and your income is way too high and this
is white
yeah you know um i think troy is right
when i was in san diego i shouldn't have
eaten food or i should i should have
just stayed in my hotel room eating
crackers that's what i should have done
the fact that i went to a restaurant and
liked it
clearly shows
that i am an out of touch elitist i i
did i i did consume food
uh and that was a biological need i will
mention these folks are really really
strange we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today joe biden has announced
the first
pardons of his presidency
75 commutations and three pardons will
be granted to people charged with
low-level drug offenses or non-violent
crimes
this is presumably just the beginning
we're going to talk about these 78
pardons and commutations on today's
bonus show
we have now learned that the pandemic
has erased a decade of public preschool
gains
we had seen over the 10 years leading up
to the pandemic
increased funding and enrollment in
state-based preschool programs now we
can argue what's the best type of of
preschool program and that has the best
outcomes sure that's a debate we can
have but we had worked to fund and
enroll kids in preschool
that gain has been completely undone by
the pandemic and it has not resumed so
far
depressing depressing and lastly we're
going to take a deeper dive at elon
musk's
claim that he wants to bring real free
speech to twitter
his track record on speech is a little
shaky when it comes to unions and when
it comes to different things so we're
going to be looking into that and
evaluating what is likely to happen on
twitter we talked at the top of the show
about uh the losses of followers among
many left-wing accounts and the gains of
followers among many right-wing accounts
we're going to dive more deeply into the
free speech elements of this all of
those stories are on today's bonus show
i would love for you to sign up for the
bonus show it's easy you go to
joinpakman.com
you just sign up you can pay monthly you
can pay yearly you can use the coupon
code wow 22 to get a discount and very
importantly if you already have a
membership and you want to do a little
more we now have a running list of
people who want a free membership people
who want a membership but can't afford
one there are currently 700 people
waiting
700 people
waiting
for a membership they're just sitting
around waiting
you can fulfill one of their dreams or
many
by checking the this is a gift box when
you go through the sign up process on
our website it's the normal process but
there's a box that asks is this a gift
you check it
and then
the next person in line of the 700 will
get a free membership which is a
beautiful thing
i will see you on the bonus show
otherwise we'll be back tomorrow